[Music]
as the investigation into the mass
shooting in colorado continues it's hard
to
truly understand the shock and the grief
that survivors are feeling we spoke with
three people in the state
who know that pain all too well zach
cartaya survived the shooting at
columbine high school back in 1999 he
was just 17 years old at the time
and hid in a classroom heather dearman's
cousin was hurt during the aurora movie
theater shooting in 2012 and her
cousin's young daughter was killed
and ryan borowski was inside king
super's grocery store on monday
when he suddenly heard the gunshots our
lead national correspondent david bagno
met with them at a park in boulder
to discuss david good morning again it's
a club nobody wants to belong to
that's right gail look they're
essentially neighbors i mean columbine
aurora and boulder are within a one-hour
drive of each other
boulder just so happens to be the site
of america's latest massacre
between the second and third shot
i was running a terrified woman's face
was running towards me and i turned and
ran with her
and
i think she kept up with me i think
there was somebody right in front of me
i'm not having nightmares it's just this
bad daydream that like maybe there was
somebody in my peripheral vision who i
had blinders on towards
meaning that you wish you could have
grabbed them and taken them with you
alerted them that this is the exit this
is the way like you have to move you
have to run
i am just i feel for you so much i know
it
it must feel so raw for you and like
it's unreal
but my mind immediately went back to
thinking of my my cousins in the theater
and they just went to see a movie and
that someone would have to go through
this again already
i'm so so sorry to your point heather i
can't believe we're here again
here we are again was it surreal i just
remember it being so
surreal that first we thought it was a
senior prank we thought that someone was
you know we thought it was a senior
prank or or you hoped it right
well at that point in time it wasn't a
reality for us right there was there
you never ever would have thought that
someone was coming into your school or
you know name the list of places with a
with a weapon
the first shot uh now i'm describing it
as like
i hope that's not a gunshot the second
shot
shattered that hope and the third shot i
knew it was gunfire
i can't imagine that i'm hearing these
things again
and that people have to go about their
regular daily lives having to worry
about getting shot at and
i'm still in shock i was just at the
memorial i probably shouldn't have gone
there before i came here
what happened to your daughter there's a
big hug
waiting for you there when you're ready
there's so many people there
so many people putting flowers praying
what do you want to happen now i want
everybody to take responsibility for
themselves
from the bottom and i want the
government to do some common sense stuff
from the top they know what that is
heather i see you shaking your head i
don't want to be
pessimistic but i i lost all hope
back in 2012 after
we had just laid a six-year-old to rest
in
october but then just two months later
sandy hook happened
and then after nothing happened after
that i stopped listening
i stopped paying attention it has to go
back to
um starting from just you as a person
just being kind to one another and
treating people like human beings is
counting on kindness
enough it's not but our hope's all we
have i have hope
but um i'm also terrified
um
i've i've um i have hope
because over the past few years i have
i have learned so many self-care
techniques
um studying meditation and yoga and i'm
a massage therapist
but i've also wanted to kill myself
before
so um i'm either hopeful
that my struggles with that feeling
um have prepared me
um for future feelings and that i can
always remain curious about the future
enough to get to the next wave
whatever it feels like i'm so proud of
you i'm i'm i believe in you
it's going to be up and down and
i hate to even think it but
the next time this happens it's going to
take you right back to where it is but
like just go back to your grounding
i mean love your family
it's should i leave the country
right um you're asking that seriously
yeah yeah we've thought about it before
there's a lot of parts about this
country that are
absolutely wonderful but there's other
parts that are
hard to tolerate and my thought to you
ryan is is
the helpless become the helpers you'll
find something beautiful in yourself too
so as a result of something so terrible
you'll find something beautiful in
yourself
find that beauty in yourself and let
that helplessness make you a helper
you know ryan who survived the boulder
shooting said i want my car
it had been kept inside the crime scene
here at the grocery store
and he said i wanted to rescue myself
and i said well what do you mean
and he said you know what's one thing
you can do inside your car he said you
can
scream as loud as you want because he
said that's not something you can do
around your loved ones gail david
my heart goes out to ryan number one you
can still feel his pain
really really appreciate his candor his
conversation with you
thank you thank you thank you so much i
like what zach said to ryan that the
helpless become the helper
i mean you can see clearly it's still
he's still struggling with it and what
heather said the next time it happens
because we all know there's going to be
a next time
you can see how triggering this is for
everybody who's been through that and
you can see how much heather is still
struggling
amazing we all accept that it's going to
happen again yes makes no sense